there's no hiding from this son we have
a job to do
this is a film where you're so immersed
that I highly urge people to sit on the
biggest screen possible because it truly
is an experience that will take your
breath away soon as I saw the screen it
was like wow never seen a screen like
that before in my life
the screen is so huge that you really
can't see the end of it you're just sort
of caught in the middle of it all you
look up you're looking at the screen you
look down you're looking at the screen
idiot the planet the most don't notice
it I am actually going on in the normal
foot forcing the sound system felt so
amazing and you just feel as though like
the explosion for going on next to you
on kale spectacularity peel vacuum is
due to the develop my heart rate is
still through the roof there are
homeless and extractions there's so many
things that can sort of take you out of
the experience of having when you're
here there's no escaping the whole film
from the very decos just so intense the
movie was shot in IMAX film and so
you're just seeing it somewhere else
just wouldn't do it justive couldn't pay
me to see a movie made by Christopher
Nolan anywhere else
you